je m'appelle Sarah j'ai 12 ans
j'habite à Strasbourg et à l'école est
dans la rue on mettra des saletés et de
caméléon et je trouve que c'est injuste
je m'appelle Sarah j'ai 47 ans et je
vous racontais ce que je suis devenu
[Musique]
nous sommes en 1989 Sarah témoigne à la
télévision des moqueries qu'elle subit
quotidiennement au collège à l'époque le
mot harcèlement n'est pas prononcé
un petit problème de la vie quotidienne
je dis bien un petit problème parce que
vous allez voir qu'à mon avis les choses
peuvent très bien s'arranger pendant
plus tard on la retrouvait du côté du
Mans et elle a accepté pour vous de
revenir sur cette archive alors ces
missions c'est l'émission venait de
débuter et l'objectif ça s'appelait
c'est pas juste et l'objectif c'était en
fait permettre à des jeunes de parler
d'un problème sur lequel ils étaient
trouvés qu'il y avait une injustice et
c'est venu sur lors d'un repas madame
qui propose à des jeunes de s'exprimer
sur des injustices que tu as envie de
participer à cette émission je crois
avoir dit bah oui ça va commencer quand
je suis arrivée au collège
des garçons de 5e et ça a duré toute
l'année j'ai ressenti beaucoup de
nostalgie à la vue de cette de cette
vidéo parce que ça me fait revenir à
qui j'étais petite fille quand j'avais
12 ans et j'avais vachement aimé
finalement ce reportage le revoir 35 ans
après avec des yeux d'adultes c'est
complètement différent
moi non
tu fais pas un peu tu les provoques pas
un peu les autres de temps en temps non
ils ont commencé je l'ai déjà je les
connaissais pas ils ont commencé je les
ai jamais provoqué j'essaye de pas les
écouter mais c'est plus fort que moi
j'arrive pas
il me voit ils me disent que ils ont
envie de vomir et des trucs comme ça
devient une forme de la récréation et
puis il avait des un groupe de garçons
il commençait ils étaient tout autour de
nous et puis il commence à dire il
insulté il dit sale tête et tout et
Sarah c'est pourquoi faire
un beau tapis soyeux et donc là le fait
d'être revenu à la surface ça m'a
réveillé les souvenirs pas forcément
heureux des fois un peu douloureux aussi
mais nécessaire aujourd'hui
tout le monde depuis 20 ans je suis
expert retraite
je suis venue au moment parce que mon
mari vivait là
qui était déjà bien installé
professionnelment donc c'était plus
simple de faire bouger moi et puis
c'était à mon avis à mon sens une autre
étape de ma vie moi ça me dérange pas je
suis parti à l'aventure
c'est une ville familiale c'est une
ville faite pour les familles
de trois enfants qui sont des vrais
adolescents mes enfants ont vu l'archive
qui a été diffusé sur Lina sur moi ils
ont un regard très bienveillant mes
enfants ils trouvaient que j'étais très
courageuse d'avoir fait ça à cet âge-là
et donc oui ils étaient assez
impressionnés de ce que j'avais vécu et
puis triste aussi en quatrième c'est 14
ans et bah je suis au collège quoi bah
je savais qu'on l'avait connu parlait
pas très bien mais je savais pas qu'elle
avait été harcelée je veux dire pas
comme ça
[Musique]
est-ce que tu te souviens comment ça ça
a débuté ces histoires on a une petite
dispute moyenne en sortant comme ça
alors là je commence à l'appeler
caméléon et ça ça continue comme ça
quelques jours après pour moi
l'harcèlement c'est quelque chose qui
dure sur le long terme et si bah il lui
faisait ça tous les jours pour moi c'est
une sorte de harcèlement ils attendent
de ta part beaucoup de réactions est-ce
que tu en as beaucoup parce qu'en fait
on ne sait pas comment elle réagit ben
est-ce que tu réagis assez mal mais tu
cries tu tu les insultes à ton tour
qu'est-ce que tu fais je crée elle fait
tout un cirque alors c'est pour ça que
je crois aussi que pour les autres
garçons alors ça les amuse alors ça il
continue à aller la maltraiter comme ça
il l'utilise le mot maltraitait quand
même il continue à la maltraiter donc il
faut savoir parce qu'il y a eu aussi
d'autres personnes qui ont dit oui mais
comment ça se fait sur ce tu es sur ce
plateau il y avait les bourreaux mais
c'est trop violent pour elle et tout
c'était une demande de ma part à mon
sens c'était important qu'il puisse
aussi s'exprimer parce que dans dans une
relation et même dans une relation qui
est aussi difficile que harcèlement il y
a deux parties il faut entendre les deux
il faut entendre les débarquer mais le
fait d'en avoir discuté d'avoir posé
dire voilà voilà ce que je dis voilà ce
que je souffre je pense que ça a été
aussi révélateur chez les autres pour
quelqu'un qui aime se moquer des gens
s'arrêtent une cible extraordinaire
absolument je crois que Sarah est une
petite fille vous le voyez tous c'est
une petite fille très vivante très
dynamique et je pense qu'elle concentre
autour d'elle beaucoup d'attention alors
du coup peut-être la vôtre aussi alors
elle vous plaît aussi puisqu'elle vous
amuse est-ce que tu crois que même en
dominant le plus possible tu aurais du
mal à essayer de te faire abstraction de
tout ça et quand on t'ennuie comme ça de
faire comme si de rien n'était
pas vraiment essayé comme ça ils ont pas
à me traiter comme ça vraiment ils ont
pas de raison je le vois je me dis mais
pourquoi il me posait ces questions là
et tout alors il y a une dans les
commentaires il y a des gens qui ont
pointé du doigt ça son positionnement à
Vincent Perrot alors il était aussi très
jeune et peut-être que il avait pas
encore le recul nécessaire et je j'ai de
la pierre à personne et comment tu la
trouves ta maman alors très très
courageuse parce que même bah avant
après je la connaissais pas avant mais
maintenant je la trouve courageuse elle
le fait toujours tout pour nous elle est
toujours là qu'on a besoin ta maman est
avec nous sur le plateau aujourd'hui
bonjour madame bienvenue vous êtes
l'avocate de votre fille évidemment vous
avez été un petit peu témoin certaines
scènes ou pas témoins mais surtout
interpellé par ma fille parce que ça
avait pris effectivement dans le moment
des proportions insupportables ma mère
je pouvais en parler de manière très
très libre j'avais pas j'ai jamais été
empêché de parler
on avait beaucoup de discussions et on
en a eu très longtemps après encore
madame la Présidente je réitère ma
question grave ou pas grave
pas grave je crois que maintenant on va
comprendre des choses on va s'agir je
crois on va aller vers plus de
profondeur et on va grandir on veut
grandir un peu sûrement alors à l'époque
me dit bon bah on essaye de on essaie de
dédramatiser la situation
potentiellement est-ce que maintenant on
ferait la même chose je sais pas à
l'époque je pense qu'on était encore
très attention on essaie pas de rentrer
dans la serre privée tu as l'impression
quand même à la fin de l'émission que ça
dédramatisé un petit peu maintenant que
j'ai appris pourquoi on m'appeler de
caméléon
tout le monde a essayé de d'y mettre son
grain de sel de pas trop faire de mal
mais en étant dit oui mais finalement
c'est pas c'est grave que ça donc
c'était c'est vrai que c'était pas grave
comparé aujourd'hui mais à l'époque se
dire qu'on sort dehors et que on est
connu comme le loup blanc pour être la
seule tête ou calmer non de mon regard
de petit c'était douloureux
est-ce que
ces moqueries se sont arrêtés au collège
après la diffusion dans mes souvenirs
oui elles se sont arrêtées ces moqueries
dans mon souvenir mais c'est mon
souvenir qui comme je vous ai dit j'ai
mis un certain nombre de choses sous un
tapis et peut-être que non ça c'est pas
arrêté du jour au lendemain et oui
effectivement il y a des harcèlements
qui se rendent pas compte de l'impact
parce que au début du reportage du bruit
mais c'était juste une moquerie sauf que
on ne s'amuse pas d'une moquerie quelle
qu'elle soit c'est pour ça il faut les
combattre mon message c'est dire moi
j'ai réussi à dépasser parce que j'ai
été aimé aider accompagné parce que j'ai
une force de caractère qui fait que je
me laisserai jamais abattre mais surtout
c'est que quand on vit ce genre de
choses il faut surtout pas rester dans
son coin parce que ça fait des désastres
après c'est terrible et on peut ne pas
en revenir pendant longtemps j'ai voulu
absolument qu'on aime tout était il
fallait que je fasse tout pour qu'on
m'aime à mon avis m'ont permis
d'apprendre à m'aimer tel que je suis et
à m'affirmer telle que je suis
[Musique]